en france il ya mois disparaissait la
petite estelle à la sortie de l'école
depuis le travail des inspecteurs et les
moyens mis en place ont été
considérables mais aucune trace de la
fillette de 9 ans l'émotion et
l'inquiétude grandit un peu plus chaque
jour dans le petit village de guermantes
yves martinet bruno bini disparu depuis
un mois aujourd'hui
un mois durant lequel les parents des
stèles ont tout fait tout essayé d appel
à témoins d'abord affiché partout en
france mais aussi un site internet grâce
auquel une immense chaîne de solidarité
a vu le jour
malgré ses moyens toujours rien ça fait
un mois qu'on a aucune aucune piste
aucune information aucun élément nouveau
aucun élément matériel aucune idée sur
laquelle on puisse asseoir notre action
donc on est face au vide total donc
c'est ce que j'ai dis je c'est une
excellente forme de torture
côté enquête les policiers ont passé les
environs au peigne fin sondé plusieurs
étangs procédé à un millier d'auditions
avant de s'intéresser à tous les
délinquants sexuels connu dans la région
dix personnes ont été placées en garde à
vue en vain à guermantes la population
encore choqué vacille entre crainte et
espoir
les gens parlent toujours se pose
toujours beaucoup de questions ça c'est
certain mais bon on tourne un peu en
rond on a beau se poser plein de
questions
on voit vraiment pas ce qui a pu se
passer quoi on se demande donc j'ai peur
que ça cette s'atténue tout doucement et
qu'on arrive à oublier
et ça faut pas oublier les initiatives
pour retrouver estelle se multiplient
prochainement une association verra le
jour et dans la semaine c'est ta fiche
de 4 mètres par 3 sera placardée sur un
millier de panneaux publicitaires en
france cela fait maintenant deux mois
que la petite estelle a disparu à la
sortie de l'école à guermantes en
seine-et-marne deux mois et malgré une
très forte mobilisation toujours aucune
piste sérieuse
ce matin une banderole humaine a été
déployée au départ du semi marathon de
paris
une initiative de l'association estelle
qui veut encore y croire
sophie guihomat et christophe alary
aidez nous à retrouver estelle ce
message 14 mille coureurs ont pu le lire
ce matin sur la ligne de départ du semi
marathon de paris
ce sont les proches de la petite fille
disparue il ya deux mois jour pour jour
qui ont eu l'idée d'associer ainsi
symboliquement leur combat à la
manifestation sportive
j'ai quand même des deux grandes
similitudes entre une course de fond
semi marathon
notre combat puisque c'est
l'effort va durer
la distance
l'acharnement
le but à atteindre la ligne d'arrivée à
franchir cette ligne d'arrivée les
proches des stèles ont tout essayé
depuis deux mois pour y parvenir
campagne d'affichage dans les rues les
aéroports les gares création d'un site
internet publication d'un avis de
recherche par plus de 500 entreprises
rien n'y a fait les initiatives doivent
donc se poursuivre le but c'est de ne
pas renoncer fait que l'on considère qu
est l
certainement que quelque part qu'il nous
faut la retrouver et qui a peut-être des
gens
qui ont des informations qui peut-être
n'ose pas encore
c'est par donc diffusé à être présent
diffuser l'avis de recherche
c'est je crois lors de leur dire à
nouveau on a besoin de vous un appel à
l'aide d'autant plus pressant que l'
enquête semble piétiner perquisitions à
grande échelle fouille systématique de
véhicules et autres interrogatoires de
suspects n'ont mené nulle part les
parents de la petite fille ne dispose à
ce jour d'aucune information qui leur
permettrait même de deviner ce qu'est
devenu leur enfant depuis qu'elle a
disparu
en sortant de la boulangerie de
guermantes le 9 janvier dernier pour la
première fois la france participera
demain à une journée internationale des
enfants disparus
à titre exceptionnel et pour l'occasion
nous avons décidé de recueillir à sa
demande
l'appel du père d'estelle qui s'adresse
aux ravisseurs malgré tous les efforts
entrepris par les enquêteurs aucune
piste n'est aucune nouvelle à ce jour de
la fillette de 9 ans disparu depuis le 9
janvier 2003 amaury guibert bernie
mériaux il se décrit lui même comme un
acharné eric mouzin le père d'estelle se
rend tous les quinze jours à la police
judiciaire de versailles là une cellule
de 9 enquêteurs s'occupe exclusivement
de sa fille
je pense que pour l' enquête pour le
groupe restait la même chose que pour
nous c'est un défi et un défi c'est fait
pour être gagné tentatives depuis la
disparition d'estelle le 9 janvier tout
a été tenté affiches géantes création
d'une association et d'un site internet
eric mouzin est même devenu une figure
de la télévision
ce jour-là il participe à une émission
sur les enfants disparus
pour lutter contre l'oubli pour susciter
un témoignage qui relancera l'anc est
depuis cet hiver les recherches
piétinent malgré des moyens
exceptionnels tout le village de
guermantes a été perquisitionné en vain
la thèse de l'enlèvement est privilégiée
mais les pistes manque alors le père
d'estelle nous a contactés il renouvelle
son appel à d'éventuels ravissent
j'ignore qui vous êtes et où vous vous
trouvez je suis en revanche certain que
vous m'entendez et que vous en sentez
flatté et ce n est pas une chose que
l'on peut garder comme cela estelle est
une enfant qui doit retrouver sa liberté
et sa famille quand il ait pu arriver à
estelle vous devez nous la rendre il n'y
a pas dans ce message de marchandage ni
d'appel à quelque forme d'humanité qui
pourrait être en vous vous avez commis
un acte monstrueux et vous ne faites pas
partie du genre humain
je ne suis pas un justicier je suis
simplement un père qui veut retrouver sa
fille
les suites qui seront données à cette
affaire par la justice ne m'intéresse
pas aujourd'hui mais n'espérez pas
l'impunité
en france il y à chaque année en moyenne
une disparition d'enfant qui reste
inexpliquée
la relance de l'enquêté sur la
disparition de la petite estelle c'était
il ya 10 - nouvelle opération de grande
envergure aujourd'hui deux à trois cents
familles vont traiter entrendre vont
être entendus dans les trois jours qui
viennent christelle bertrand sylvain
novation place rassemblés pour la
deuxième fois cette centaine de
policiers est là pour auditionner 300
familles en trois jours depuis la
disparition de la petite estelle mouzin
le 9 janvier 2003 les enquêteurs n'ont
aucune trace de l'enfant d'une première
vague d'auditions en juin dernier était
ressorti un portrait robot dressé par
une copine d'école qui aurait été
importunée par un homme
trois semaines avant la disparition
d'estelle qualifié d'important ce témoin
est toujours introuvable
les portraits-robots reste d'actualité
comme il ya un certain nombre d'autres
pistes qui restent d'actualité pour
lesquels nous nous exprimons pas
directement
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'il ya le
maximum de moyens possibles qui est
mises en oeuvre dans cette affaire pour
parvenir à la solution et raviver les
mémoires et traquer le moindre indice
les enquêteurs gardent espoir autant que
les habitants continuent leur enquête
et puis peut-être qu'ils trouveront
quelque chose moi je ne sais pas un seul
petit détail pourrait permettre de faire
avancer l'enquêté
c'est pour cela que les policiers vont
interroger la population des villages
voisins de guermantes
l' enquête sur la disparition de la
petite estelle en région parisienne elle
a donné lieu à la plus importantes
opérations de police jamais menée dans
les milieux pédophiles 75
interpellations
toutes les personnes déjà condamnées et
qui ont un lien plus ou moins direct
avec la zone de disparition ont été
entendus avec de la monnaie bruno bini
et chloé le compte il fait encore nuit
tôt ce matin mais ces policiers sont
déjà à pied d'oeuvre dans cette maison
de seine et marne
les enquêteurs vont fouiller chaque
recoin pour trouver des indices
vêtements des stèles coupures de presse
mais ils vont surtout saisir le disque
dur de l'ordinateur à la recherche
d'éventuelles images pédophiles
le locataire de cette maison a déjà été
poursuivi pour attouchements sexuels
il fait partie d'une des 84 cibles
visées par cette large descente de
police en effet au même instant
l'opération se répète dans toute la
france comme ici à lille au total 450
policiers ont été mobilisés
ce n'est pas une opération la dernière
chance parce que l'anc elles seraient au
point mort que l'on ne saurait plus quoi
faire
ce n'est absolument pas sans nous sommes
dans la logique d'une enquête d'une
enquête au long cours
les suspects sont ensuite emmenés en
garde à vue ils vont être interrogés sur
leur emploi du temps
le 9 janvier 2003 jour de la disparition
d'estelle
ils vont également subir un prélèvement
de salive destiné à alimenter le fichier
adn de la police le décret qui le leur
permet est tout frais il a été publié
hier au journal officiel
les enquêteurs n'ont pas perdu une
minute mais malgré la diffusion en juin
dernier du portrait robot d'un suspect
malgré les efforts des dix-sept
policiers permanents de la cellule est
elle l'enquète n'a toujours pas abouti
ce soir la plupart des suspects ont été
relâchés mais pour la police il ya déjà
un point positif le nombre de pédophiles
recensés dans le fichier des empreintes
génétiques a augmenté il ya tout juste
un an le 9 janvier 2003 la petite
estelle alors âgée de 9 ans
disparaissait à guermantes en
seine-et-marne
malgré des moyens considérables la
fillette reste introuvable
aucune piste précise même si la police
désormais convaincus qu'il s'agit d'un
enlèvement prémédités mûrement préparée
à guermantes où les habitants restent
traumatisés une marche silencieuse sera
organisée demain matin
retour sur cette mystérieuse affaire
avec philippe castel et philippe hermant
doigt des battues avaient été organisées
des lacs sont des des forêts fouillis
mais est elle reste introuvable
elle a disparu le 9 janvier vers 18h à
guermantes sans doute près de cette
boulangerie
personne n'a rien vu et ça fait m le
père d'estelle depuis se refuse à
imaginer l'inacceptable j'ai pas envie
de devenir le spécialiste du scénario de
l'horreur donc c'est parti là ne
présente pas d'intérêt
ce que vous êtes découragé non jamais
vous avez toujours l'espoir de retrouver
bien sûr neuf enquêteurs de la police
judiciaire de versailles travail à temps
plein sur dossier des stèles il ya six
mois
un portrait robot a été tirée et une
voiture suspecte désigné jamais une
enquête n'a bénéficié d'autant de moyens
450 policiers gendarmes ont auditionné
l'ensemble de la population de
guermantes et des interrogatoires ont
été menées plus récemment dans les
milieux pédophiles de toute la france
pour aboutir à une conviction n'a pu
déterminer que ce fait était très
vraisemblablement imputable à un
individu disons un pédophile à ce que
l'on appelle un prédateur c'est à dire
un individu qui qui s'est donné les
moyens de piste et une jeune fille
peut-être pas forcément estelle de la
suivre et au moment où elle se trouvait
seule sans qu' il y ait grand monde
autour d'elle et bien de l'inciter à de
l'apprendre de s'enfuir avec elle cette
thèse est partagée par le père d'estelle
qui se souvient d'une tentative
d'enlèvement opéré quelques jours
auparavant
aguer morte le jeudi de la dernière
semaine de classe du mois de décembre
une petite fille fait l'objet d'une
tentative d'enlèvement qui heureusement
n'a pas pu se produire estelle a été
enlevé la première semaine de la rentrée
des classes
le même jour à la même heure donc
effectivement la préméditation sans
l'état dit un an plus tard le père
d'estelle combat un autre danger
l'oubli l'anc est sûre la disparition de
la petite estelle mouzin est elle
relancée après un an et demi
d'investigations sans résultat sept
personnes ont été interpellées dont un
homme qui habitait guermantes et a
déménagé après la diffusion d'un
portrait robot mois de juin il a été
placé en garde à vue à compiègne
philippe castel philippe hernando sous
cette couverture une des sept personnes
interpellées par la police judiciaire de
versailles peut-être le principal
suspect hier soir vers 18 heures les
enquêteurs qui travaillent sur la
disparition d'estelle mouzin
perquisitionnent cette résidence
secondaire de mire en cours dans l'oise
il y interpellent un homme de 34 ans ce
matin des fouilles sont man entreprises
dans le jardin au total six personnes de
l'entourage du témoin principal sont
emmenés par la police dont la femme qui
fréquente et yann l la hébergés ici à
conches un village qui se situe juste à
côté de guermantes
là où a disparu estelle mouzin le 9
janvier 2003 mais soudain l'homme des
ménages en juin dernier lorsqu un
portrait robot est dressé par la police
judiciaire de versailles
les policiers se rendent compte en
décembre 2003 lors d'une rare chf sur
une centaine de pédophiles que lui il
manque à l'appel
ce n'est pas vraiment un pédophile
d'ailleurs il n'a jamais été condamné
mais seulement soupçonnés en 2002
d'attouchements sur ses neveux et nièces
les policiers le retrouvent finalement
il y a quelques jours à muirancourt dans
l'oise il m'avait dit qu'il était
heureux
on dispute avec ses parents et qu'il
était nu se met à me plaire ici
aux policiers il déclare en fait il
s'est mis au vert parce qu'il devait une
importante somme d'argent à des dealers
de cannabis de seine et marne
il était d'ailleurs lui même connu des
services de police pour cela et c'est
peut-être à ce titre et non pas en tant
que suspect dans la liste
mission des stars nous a que sa garde à
vue pourrait être prolongé d'ailleurs
selon des témoins le portrait robot ne
lui ressemble pas du tout la personne
était quand même assez le thème de ma
taille environ un peu trapu les blondes
plus ou moins blond jeu frisés et qui ne
correspond pas du tout au portrait robot
ce soir le procureur de la république de
mou qui devait tenir une conférence de
presse l'annuler se bornant à préciser
qu'il ne fallait tirer aucune conclusion
hâtive
dix ans après la disparition à
guermantes de la petite estelle neuf ans
un arbre du souvenir a été planté tout
près de l'endroit où la fillette a été
aperçue pour la dernière fois de zande
enquête tous azimuts les malgré des
opérations de très grande ampleur
aucune piste sérieuse est toujours la
ténacité du père d'estelle qui refusent
de baisser les bras nicolet luizet
annick rivoire un arbre symbole d'espoir
plantées à proximité du lieu où est elle
a été aperçue pour la dernière fois
c'était ici à guermantes
il y a déjà deux ans depuis le premier
instant je me suis dit que beaucoup de
mon énergie seraient consacrés à sable
et j'essaye de tenir le cap et de ne pas
perdre une peine dissipées et arrive au
résultat comme lui
tous espèrent ici qu'un jour cette
disparition sera élucidée en silence
des centaines de personnes sont venues
apporter leur soutien à la famille pour
castel ne soit pas oublié j'espère que
malgré tout le soutien continuera aux
familles auxquelles l enquête ne
s'arrêterait pas là on peut pas rester
indifférent
c'est effectivement un moment fort qui
malheureusement se répète tous les tous
les ans depuis deux années
on aimerait bien que ça soit ça s'arrête
un peu plus tôt dans l'après midi aux
côtés de la famille
le directeur du srpj de versailles a
tenu à faire le point sur les enquêtes
après deux ans donc c'est d'abord la
piste locale
on ne vient pas enlever une petite fille
de cet âge de 9 ans a entre qui sort de
l'école alors qu'il fait moins neuf
degrés alors qu'il ya du verglas et que
les conditions de circulation sont
extrêmement difficiles
c'est le 9 janvier 2003 estelle mouzin
disparaissent sur le chemin du retour de
l'école
très vite des recherches sont
entreprises
un portrait robot diffusé mais la
fillette reste introuvable
tout a été tenté affichage site internet
répondeur téléphonique en vain en mai
dernier six suspects sont interpellés
puis mis hors de cause
pour la famille d'estelle 24 mois de
faux espoirs deux heures et demi après
la disparition d'estelle mouzin à
guermantes en seine-et-marne la police
essaie de relancer son enquête pendant
tout le mois de juin une soixantaine de
jeunes victimes d'agressions ou de
tentative d'agression dans toute l'île
de france vont être entendus amaury
guibert et à la location
c'est depuis le début une enquête hors
norme
tout un village perquisitionné débattu
géante organisée 130 personnes placées
en garde à vue après la disparition
d'estelle mouzin le 9 janvier 2003 à
guermantes en seine-et-marne
les enquêteurs n'ont négligé aucune
piste aujourd'hui il se lance dans une
nouvelle opération d'envergure analyser
une soixantaine de dossiers d'agression
sexuelle de mineurs
de 2002 à 2005 en ile de france en tout
cas on sait qu'il ya certains enfants
qui ont signalé qu'ils avaient
ou qu'ils avaient été abordés et qui
avait mis en parallèle ce qui leur était
arrivé avec la disparition d'estelle
et je pense qu'en les mettant tous en
essayant d'exploiter toutes les
informations on pourra savoir retrouver
un avis qui mentent jusqu'à présent on
part des portraits-robots qui ont été
établies dans le cadre de ces affaires
là puisque sur les affaires dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de portrait
robot
on peut difficilement procéder à un
recoupement de liens toutes les
informations collectées seront rentrés
dans le système salvac c'est une base de
données qui permet de recouper
différentes affaires pour remonter
éventuellement un même criminel on a une
vision globale de l'ensemble des faits
commis sur le territoire national
contrairement à l'enquêteur qui va avoir
le nez dans le guidon et qui lui n'a pas
la possibilité de ces quartiers de son
dossier mais l'espoir reste mince de
relancer une enquête qui est au point
mort malgré deux ans et demi d'une
mobilisation menée sans relâche par les
proches des stand un triste anniversaire
pour la famille d'estelle mouzin il y a
quatre ans disparaissait à guermantes la
fillette âgée de 9 ans les enquêteurs
continuent de travailler sans relâche ce
sans pour autant avoir de pistes
sérieuses tout exploré l'hypothèse de
rattacher la disparition d'estelle à
michel fourniret
le tueur en série est écartée à l'heure
qu'il est cécilia douche estelle mouzin
c'est cette petite fille de 9 ans
disparu depuis quatre ans à la sortie de
son école à guermantes personne n'a
oublié cet après midi sa famille
accompagnée de 150 personnes se sont
rassemblées pour connaître la vérité sur
cette disparition
extrêmement dur
savoir comment pour un seul en tête un
temps évoqué la piste de michel
fourniret le tueur en série des ardennes
accusé du meurtre de cette jeune fille
semblerait s'estomper le tueur
disposerait d'un alibi sa présence en
belgique au moment de l'enlèvement des
stèles l'écarterait provisoirement du
dossier il n'y a rien actuellement dans
le dossier concernant l'allaitement
d'estelle mouzin qui directement ou
indirectement impliqués
michel fourniret cependant il ya encore
des recherches à faire pour s'assurer
qu'il était bien en sart-custinne en
belgique dans son domicile le 9 janvier
2003 après quatre ans d'investigations
les policiers confirment que l' enquête
n'est pas mise en sommeil depuis quatre
semaines le groupe bancaire travaille
sur un nouvel axe de recherche
quatre ans après sa disparition les
enquêteurs chargés de l'affairé estelle
mouzin sur sa famille qu'il ne relâchent
pas leurs efforts après avoir écarté une
application de michel fourniret dans la
disparition de la fillette il
s'intéresse à une autre tentative dans
les enlèvements qui pourrait les mener
sur la piste du ravisseurs de la petite
estelle philippe castel edouard da costa
elle aurait 13 ans mais est elle a
disparu le 9 janvier 2003 la sortie de
son école
une disparition sans témoin sans indices
comme un mystère avec un père qui depuis
quatre ans se demande comment sa fille a
pu se volatiliser
un soir de janvier pour les chants qui
sont étrangers ou de même
judiciaire c'est extrêmement dur de
savoir comment pourrait-il en tête
l'autre à savoir cela fait pourtant
quatre ans qu ici à versailles
neuf enquêteurs travaillent
quotidiennement sur le dossier estelle
mouzin 4500 procès verbaux rédigés 150
gardes à vue 400 perquisition tous les
milieux pédophiles écumé sans aucun
résultat
et puis il est l'ombre de michel
fourniret qui a plané sur la sphère et
si le tueur en série était également le
prédateur des stèles une fausse piste
conclu aujourd'hui ensemble procureurs
et enquêteurs
aujourd'hui rien directement ou
indirectement ne le rattache à l'
enquête sur la disparition d'estelle
mais il y a encore des vérifications à
faire michel fourniret n'est pas encore
totalement sorti du dossier les
enquêteurs ont donc retourné en belgique
à la fin du mois pour écarter
définitivement la piste fourniret
mais aussi pour en explorer une autre ce
portrait robot du ravisseur présumé
d'estelle mouzin aurait été reconnu par
une fillette victime d'une tentative
d'enlèvement dans le sud du pays
le véhicule utilisé était dans son cas
aussi une cabane est blanche
c'est au travers de d'autres tentatives
qui concerne d'autres jeunes filles
qu'on pourra se rapprocher de celui qui
a commis l'enlèvement des stèles et ce
n'est certainement pas un fait isolé et
s'il existe des faits similaires en
belgique les faits qui peuvent se
rapprocher de la disparition d'estelle
c'était évidemment impératif d'enquêté
dessus ça permettra peut-être de trouver
enfin la piste recherché quatre ans plus
tard c'est ce qu'espère toujours les
parents d'estelle mouzin la justice
encore avec peut-être une piste cinq ans
après la disparition de la petite
estelle mouzin suite à un renseignement
les policiers cherchent ce soir encore
les traces d'un corps d'enfants dans les
fondations d'un restaurant en seine et
marne et dix personnes sont en garde à
vue les enquêteurs restaient très
prudents et discrets
lionel feirstein marie cazaux
c'est sans doute la première piste
sérieuse depuis la disparition d'estelle
mouzin
mais elle est encore très fragile en fin
de matinée une dizaine d'enquêteurs du
srpj de versailles
entre dans ce restaurant chinois de brie
comte robert
leur but vérifier les dires d'un
informateur en décembre dernier un homme
prend contact avec la police il connaît
les milieux chinois et entendu une
curieuse histoire
celle de ce restaurant un ancien local
industriel loué quelques mois auparavant
par une famille chinoise qui a engagé
d'importants travaux et les entreprises
qui sont venues effacer ces sap a été
fait aux pirates comme ça on est content
qu'ils ont passé des ratons il ya quand
même un mur complet ici qui a été coupée
n'ont pas cédé faire donc c'est pas du
travail s'est passé en garde à vue un
ouvrier chinois a avoué avoir découvert
en juillet dernier lors du creusement
d'une dalle les ossements sans savoir
dit il si c'étaient ceux d'un humain à
l'époque les restaurateurs n'ont rien
dit il se serait débarrassé de ses
ossements dans une benne à ordures les
policiers cherchent à savoir s'il en
reste d'autres sous la dalle
l'informateur de la police lui
préciserait qu'il s'agit d'une petite
fille aux cheveux longs
à côté de laquelle se trouvait un
morceau de tissu rouge
information non confirmée ce soir par
les gardés-à-vue la petite estelle
enlevés le 9 janvier 2003 à guermantes
portait précisément un petit pull rouge
brie-comte-robert se trouve à 27 km pour
les enquêteurs tous ces éléments
constituent encore une simple hypothèse
mais une hypothèse crédible
c'est une piste extrêmement sérieuse les
moyens sont mis tous les to les toutes
les recherches ont fait ça paraît
en tout cas de nature à démontrer que
des faits criminels ont été commis ce
soir une dizaine de personnes est
toujours en garde à vue
les fouilles elle ne donne rien pour
l'instant elle devrait se prolonger
toute la soirée
l'anc est sûre la disparition d'estelle
mouzin c'était une fausse piste les
fouilles entreprises sous un restaurant
asiatique de seine et marne n'ont
absolument rien donné sur les dix
personnes placées en garde à vue tout ce
soir ont été relâchés edouard da costa
jean d'un arrière
beaucoup de bruit pour rien malgré un
renseignement jugé crédible par les
enquêteurs les fouilles d'envergure
menée dans ce restaurant n'ont rien
donné sous l'imposante dalle de béton
démoli en quelques heures les policiers
l'ont finalement découvert que trois
fragments d'os d'origine animale il n'y
avait aucune trace de cadavres d'enfants
l'avocat du père d'estelle mouzin
espérait une toute autre issue à ce qui
s'avère être une nouvelle fois une
fausse piste
je serai le dernier a reproché aux
policiers de mettre tout en oeuvre pour
chercher les raisons pour lesquelles
estelle a disparu
donc moi je ne suis pas choqué qu'on
déploie beaucoup de moyens pour essayer
de vérifier une piste d'aller chercher
les éléments et du côté de la famille
d'estelle c'est la demande qu'elle a il
faut tout faire pour retrouver les
raisons de la disparition d'estelle
qui est à l'origine de sa disparition ce
soir le père d'estelle mouzin ne
comprend pas comment la police
judiciaire a pu accorder autant de
crédit aux renseignements fournis par un
journaliste indépendant qui enquêtait
sur le milieu chinois à paris on ne
ferait pas dire que je suis abattu
comprenez bien que je ne tomberai pas
dans le piège de la compassion de la
tristesse et la douleur et tout ça moi
je combats et les étapes intermédiaires
ne m'intéresse absolument pas ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces 24 heures n'a
aucune incidence sur la suite à donner
les dernières personnes placées en garde
à vue ont été relâchées en fin d'après
midi aucune charge n'étant retenue
contre elle quant au préjudice subi par
le restaurateur dont l'établissement est
inutilisable
ce sera maintenant à la justice de le
dédommager
[Musique]